view is shared in private now at the
center of a very public route / schools
social media chat between Birmingham
teachers reveals a distinct agenda there
is a group of associated individuals in
positions of influence in schools and
governing bodies who have over a quite a
considerable period of time looked to
introduce what could be described as an
aggressive Islamist agenda into some
schools very few schools in Berlin mr.
Clark uncovered thousands of postings on
a whatsapp social media discussion group
known as the Parkview Brotherhood in one
message in May last year teacher l
speaks about the murder of drummer Lee
Rigby and willage and posts a link to
youtube it says attack on Islam please
watch and share ASAP before they remove
it London butcher incident it's a hoax
parents and teachers say this influence
was pervasive in the day-to-day running
of the school minority of the governors
were actually in particular one governor
interfering in the day-to-day running of
the school instead of being strategic
governor micromanaging me asking for the
timetables for all of the staff telling
me how the staff should be deployed to
leave their leadership team say what
kind of teacher can become it when they
should be having not taking account of
what I am actually saying the needs of
the school the report cast doubt on the
government's policy of granting more
autonomy to schools prompting a defiant
response from the Minister for education
those who seek to use this case to
undermine this government's reform
agenda will be disappointed the
expansion of the Academy program has
been one of the great success stories of
this government and the actions of a
small number of individuals will not
divert us from his path some members of
the affected community said Muslim
schools were being unfairly singled out
for criticism first we were isolated and
now we're being divided from within so
there's been no justice done to the
Muslims here no justice at all and to me
it just looks like a complete witch hunt
Peter Clark says the hardliners who took
over these schools were a minority who
intimidated the community against
speaking out but the real issue
of whether these events reflect deeper
divisions within society and the role
schools play as agents of that division
remains alpha Hirsch Sky News